hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
weiteren folge vize dies zusammen mit
simon vor dem kanal um gespielt
beziehungsweise unschwer hallöchen aloha
und auch ein schönes hallo von mir ist
wie geht's dem wechsel hatte preis
entscheidet kommt man damit anstellen
kann
ich hab auch eins wert ok wären wir beim
kranken frieden frieden
ich bin ja nur finden oder auch wenn ich
bin detektiv hatte ich auch aufstocker
irgendwo ich habe keine stöcke also alle
haben uns gedacht wir haben natürlich
wieder kommentare gelesen also ich zum
beispiel auch und habe dann erfahren
dass ich zum beispiel in zehn tagen kann
dann eher drücken kann zb auf royals
sondern sich verschiedene seiten dass
ich zum beispiel holz verbrennen kann zu
normalem holz oder sowas keine ahnung
zersägen sage ich mal
und dann bekommt man das und alles
wirklich sind ganz ganz ganz ganz viele
einstellungen
das sagt alles nix also hinter weiter
wir können uns ja gerne weiterhelfen mir
sagt dass gerade er nicht ich möchte
erstmal mein haus fertig war und danach
beschäftigen uns ein bisschen hiermit
mit viel zuließ muss auch alles ein
bisschen erst mal aufgebaut werden aber
schauen wir noch pilz zum beispiel drauf
drückt dann steht das was wie stein der
weisen und so also die ganz neue alt ist
und so teuer und außerdem bei mir in der
aufnahme gibt es jetzt auch die die
aufnahme mit einem sex puppe die kraft
und der erweiterung das heißt kein
falsches text hupac mehr also auf das
gleiche texture pack wie du ich musste
ganz kurz gucken ob ich dich im skype
laut genug argument werde auch erst mal
dass hier ein bisschen weiter bauernhaus
und dann befahren und sondern mit uns
erst mal aufgebaut haben danach rüst und
danach werden wir diesen wir wollen hier
noch in diesem
links dahin gehen und ich werde auch
dieses mal nicht so laut sein weil es
gerade schon 22 49 ist meine eltern sind
halt schon schlafen und die möchte jetzt
nicht so unbedingt aufwecken weil sonst
gibt's klatsche auf den popo ja ich
werde es auch in meinem haus oben
bisschen weiter bauen also erst mal wenn
ich mein altes haus jetzt abreißen
es sieht alles schön dass du dieses
wechselbad probierte kräftig auf jeden
fall einheitlich auswendig ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen ich habe noch nie ein
anderes text effekt als ein 16 16 text
effekt benutzt also immer schmutzig oder
hättest default text effekt genutzt und
jetzt mal so ein 64 64 paxton ganz
anderes feeling gleich mal als andere
ausmaße sofort von der qualität her da
ist so wenn ich jetzt doch wenn jetzt
der nächste star shader an kriege dann
könnt ihr das richtig schön was vor ich
versuche mal ob das pc mäßig klappt
müsste doch du hast einigen guten pc
oder wobei ich mir jetzt auch bei den
ort einholen möchte weil der unterschied
zum beispiel oft gar nicht witzig und
sie den 911 gar keine schäden
ja ich möchte sowieso 9 holen weil ich
jetzt auch schneller rendern möchte und
somit zwei pcs sowie so guthaben auf
zwei verschiedene pcs videos rennen und
so war ich möchte jetzt mein video
output im nächsten jahr nächsten zeit
erhöhen und ich möchte noch mehr da ist
aber noch mehr liefern und so ich baue
jetzt sehr stark am main kanal rum
wir könnten ja mal wieder auf kommentare
fragen eingehen und zwar hat zum
beispiel einer letztes gefragt und
seinem video warum wir uns denn
eigentlich für vize biester entschieden
habe und nicht verhängt eine normales
let's play oder so was halt ohne diese
ganzen mods stattfindet
also ich würde einfach mal die fragen
direkt zu beantworten was ist jetzt mal
einfach so ich würde sagen weil fließt
einfach viel umfangreicher es sieht man
hat mehr möglichkeiten normales let's
play finde ich ihn relativ langweilig
weil man läuft erhalte rum und jetzt
eigentlich schon ganz cool aber man
erzählt halt so sachen man redet über
themen die vorgeschlagen werden sage ich
mal
aber man hat halt ich die ganzen
möglichkeiten gewählt sie hier zum
beispiel geleast haben wir zum beispiel
komplett neue biome und hat wenig sonst
alles haben also das ist ein
ausschlaggebender grund würde ich sagen
ja einfach neue sachen kennenlernen
entdecken und so weiter genau neues
entdecken und so weiter
ja also ich finde auch einfach die
spannung weil wir kennen er selber den
ganzen items tiefe gibt also stadtrat
irgendwie gelesen stein der weisen und
solchen den ganzen quatsch
das kenne ich alles nicht und das dann
wieder für uns selber so ein kleines
neues abenteuer
man lernt halt einfach mal wenn der
januar ist in indien in dieser modernen
glaube ich nie aus das ist so einfach
hat glaubt man deswegen ist einfach ohne
das langweilig wird ohne es selber
machen können das einfach richtig lange
chancen
das macht einfach okay ich glaube ich
werde jetzt einfach mal in mein holz bei
den männer steine hier ein bisschen
beraten ich kohle habe ich natürlich
nicht und werde dann solche komischen
geheißen
stone briggs glaube ich hinsetzen und
danach wird in der rüstung machen wir
dann da hinten in die höhle schauen noch
so viel weiß ich was mir in richtung
machen und zwar brauche ich alle teile
noch kommst du damit in diese komische
ding star sondern die nächste nacht
machen was er trat dunkel
meine nächste ich habe gerade
aussichtslose machen das ist ein track
remover das ist ein trick remover ich
weiß dieses dieses eichenholz letztes
mal abgebaut haben sich in diesen zweck
coupé die kraft ja auch eigentlich ganz
schön aus also ich finde dass jetzt
gleich hier so herzlich
ich hätte mich gefreut es war so dass
ein bisschen hätte zwar nicht in ein
wenig essig ein wenig so ich habe jetzt
ich habe jetzt queenston im ofen
gebrannt letzten folge und die werde ich
jetzt hier nutzen um ein ziegel ich
mache ja auszubauen
ich werde das so ein bisschen aus stein
zu bauen und zwar so diese untere etage
ja ich hab keine ahnung ich weiß nicht
ob das irgendwie auch nicht obwohl es
geht kann so lassen ist jetzt eigentlich
schon wieder nacht gerade richtig ist
nicht gut übrigens braucht ihr dann auch
nicht denken dass wir hier viele biest
machen und uns nie dann irgendwie um die
uns andere sachen kümmern die hier
irgendwie hinzugekommen sind natürlich
wir haben jetzt erst mal gesagt dass wir
die ersten folgen uns erstmal hier etwas
aufbauen wollen und weil letzte zeit
auch ein bisschen stress haben in schule
beziehungsweise bei dir schon ausbildung
ausbildung dieser zeit wirklich so eine
phase war echt eine menge von einem
gefordert wird und vor allem bei mir mit
der facharbeiter schrecklich naja
deswegen haben wir gedacht wir
beschäftigung sammelt jetzt erstmal
nicht zu viel aber danach kommt es dann
alles mit der zeit heilt also dann
werden wir auch mehr versuche machen ich
denke wir werden mehr sachen und
nachschlagen damit ihr dann hier auch
auf eure kosten kommt damit das ganze
auf die tipps des endlich ein ex meister
play minecraft recht genau herr reimann
vom reinen text das habe ich erzählt
123456 doch jetzt kommt ihr einmal bei
facebook
das wäre es bestimmt schon profi der
doch was machst du ich zähle das ab ich
hab ich was richtig sinnlos vertan so
ich baue gerade jetzt habe ich wieder
mein haus gerade los
so wie die 820 ja ich weiss es gab ein
bisschen brat arbeit hier so ich einfach
nur warten und warten und warten muss
ich habe auch eine kommentar frage die
ich bekommen habt ihr auch für die
möchte ich eingehen
da hat jemand gefragt hey das ist
richtig blöd wenn ihr immer die ganze
das alleine macht und die anderen nach
oben so ja ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
wenn wir so ein bisschen was eigenes
machen es ist ganz so machen sich die
ganze leben jetzt gleich alt also gleich
gehen wir ja in dieses in diese ganzen
satz zusammen und schauen erst mal
genauer an
aber wir können immer die ganze alles
zusammen machen weil wir müssen uns
unsere eigene dach noch ein bisschen
aufbauen deswegen also wir werden das
schon die schon so machen das sind jetzt
die ersten folgen das hat schon gesagt
wieso kann man hört eigentlich noch
nicht stecken er das versteht nicht dass
jetzt die ersten folgen wo wir alle
unsere sachen aufbauen können jetzt
nicht so viel zusammen machen
du bist wieder ein gewisser oben auf
einem berg richtig gar nicht mehr da
kann man jetzt noch nicht so viel
zusammen machen ich denke später wenn
wir dann zusammen texte machen werden
tests machen werden
probleme mit englischen komischen will
infiniti ist natürlich gemein ist aber
das ist quatsch
dann werden wir mehr sachen zusammen
machen wir werden ja auch gleich dann in
dieses diese keine ahnung was da gehen
ich würde sagen dem dungeon das was da
unten sein wird das teil regelrecht auf
oder wer wird euch auf sand ich möchte
am liebsten erst mal eigentlich noch
meine ganzen ep speichern
ich hab 30 et wie viel hast du level 30
länder zuschauer und ab 7
ja ich habe 30 deswegen will ich sagen
dass ich eher so ein sniper mache im
boden macht um einen aufsteiger zu
machen wir das gut dann brauche ich am
boden oder habe ich hier schon eindeutig
auf jeden fall hier sind pfeile nicht es
um drogen geht es gut ich kann ich sehen
konnte
ich hoffe nicht ich gucke jetzt kommt
hoch ich sehe dich hey auch dann machen
wir können ja dann wirklich nachher so
eine seilbahn oder sowas machen dass
einem ein kart bahn ja so im kart bahn
genauso schienen baden da war dann lass
uns das doch auch mal machen das machen
wir machen schienenbahn von haus zu haus
und so ein gebiet mit theoretisch auch
machen dass wir dann immer jede jede
zwanzigste volk oder so einfach mal ein
bisschen rum lauf unserer zeigen was
sich so verändert hat weil jetzt steigen
ja wirklich immer oft öfter neue leute
ein
das habe ich auch gemerkt als ein einer
meinte er ich bin jetzt hier neu
eingestiegen bei lost und hab dann
gesehen oder stage ist ja nicht viel
aber jeder paket als 40 minuten da muss
ich wieder eine menge aufholen kann ich
mir dann gedacht ja eigentlich immer
ganz schnell wenn man so einen überblick
machen könnte noch ein paar folgen was
man bisher schon so alles gemacht hat
also das kann man ja eventuell mal
irgendwann machen ja finde ich auf jeden
fall ganz geil und sehr sozial
also den anderen user gegenüber wollen
wir pennen ist schon dunkel die sonne
geht unter die top es noch gar nicht ob
ist schon genug leute ich bin jetzt ich
gehe sofort penan ich mache ganz ehrlich
was auf dem weg zur ruhiger ort wo bist
du passt immer noch kein eigenes bett ja
ich will dabei meinen mann ist echt ein
kleiner schlawiner na ja ich hab da oben
schon jetzt mein ich mache mir dazu ein
schuss wird aber es wird irgendwann
irgendwas wird schon irgendwas wird das
immer so ich bin mal ruhiger ich gebe
auch eine etage tiefer im bett moment
habe ich die fackel dabei erhielt schon
hier oben gehwegen ungespielt 64 auf
gelbe wolle
das war eben in dem test als wäre dieses
turnier ding machen haben okay gut ich
hab jetzt schon direkt geschmissen
gucken meint hier in einer aufnahme ich
habe kein geld dabei das war ich eben
auf diese gemeldeten klickt habt ja aber
das im prozess gemacht
hinausgehen die haben die items ding
drin aber wir wissen nicht genau wie wir
es ausstellungs und zeigt nimmt aber wir
nehmen uns natürlich nie was
was wir nicht genau bekommen haben so
ich bin jetzt ich auch ob und ich bin
aufgewacht guten morgen hast du gut ich
schlafe gut geschlafen
aha ich habe sehr gut geschlafen heuer
zukunft geschlafen dann kriegt man
kriegt ganz viele cripper ganz ganz
viele mops ich erstmal den krieg
damit hat fleisch gebraten mit harman
schritte fragt simon bist du im spiel
auch vegan soll ich das machen ja also
ich mache eine fette farm auf da können
wir dann tauschen dann gebe ich den brot
oder so wenn du nur fleisch ich hab ich
grad steak aber es ist nicht ok schwer
zum spiel vegan